you know you have this whole roadmap in
your life right that you're going to get
the white picket fence you're going to
you know we bought our house lived in it
for twenty five years and then we were
going to upgrade and get a bigger house
and this has every has this vision of
what the American Dream is really all
about and then you start realizing that
the American Dream is really about not
having all this debt they just don't
know it
[Music]
my name is Ross I'm 16 years old I'm
born and raised in Modesto here I'm a
project manager for local business so my
wife and I met when I was 22 years old
and we met playing softball cuz I was a
softball coach and she was a pitcher we
got married a couple years after that
we never talked about money money was
always as long as we could pay the bills
make it work it was really never I
always thought I could out earn our debt
I before we were married we bought a
house together everything he did to us
through debt that the American Nightmare
I would cigar would call it right we
accumulated about $55,000 debt and we
actually paid off to $55,000 to five
years but one thing we didn't do is we
didn't change her behavior
you know it is a nuisance right it just
is a nuisance the keep keep keep up with
her at that point we had 12 credit cards
and they were famous maxed out and so is
just a constant thing to manage and we
were both sitting there before any of
this illness happened and how are we
going to retire in this house because we
can't afford to be in this house and
then our injury came along now all
sudden you know everything fell apart we
don't know why just your all sudden she
felt something in her neck and came in
she actually came in and said man I
can't make my body up Catholic my body
up we went into emergency and she
stopped walking says I can't walk it
[Music]
we're there got there 11 o'clock at
night and then 3 o'clock in the evening
morning they said hey everything looks
fine and we think you can go home see
your primary doctor and we were so in
shock we didn't know what to do
I got her in the car when I got home
actually this is sort of crazy but
actually when I went to lift her out she
was dead weight she couldn't couldn't
walk at all so I actually put her on a
piece of carpet and I dragged her into
the house and I can't believe we did it
but you I got her a bed roll on the bed
and on the floor and she slept there
that night and woke up that was four
hours five hours later at eight o'clock
and she was just rigid she was rigid I
mean her body was just bored right and
we called her primary doctor his call
nine-one-one you know you guys got to
get back down there
[Music]
there was always when she when she have
something like this happen all at
life-altering event happened you're just
after the next next thing what are we
doing next where are we going next what
are we doing next the co-worker we were
just out walking lunch doing our
vitality walk and she mentioned Dave
Ramsey and I wasn't even thinking about
you know our future we were focused on
trying to get Terry better we were going
to physical therapy when we came back to
Modell's so we're going three times a
week and she mentioned this guy and I
got online yeah it was within a month of
her saying that I actually literally
went online and found his website did
know anything about it found out who
this guy is
right and it was very short time period
when we decided to do this I think it
was because we had got to the point I
was so sick and tired of being in debt
and being where we were at and we didn't
know what to do next and we're trying to
figure out what is art what is our
financial future what you know what do
we have to go forward so we knew at that
moment we had to basically make a
decision we had to cut our expenses
somehow we decided to sell our house it
was the biggest chain that was a weight
that was on us really
so I got a line and I and you know I
went on to find a class and there was a
class close to us here in Modesto and my
wife said yeah let's let's try it way it
teaches us to pay off the small step
first and have that for progress that we
actually you know when you get first one
knocked out wow that actually happens
right and I and I remember my wife along
the way talking about you know how wow
we're knocking it out we're knocking out
believe me now we're believing that we
can actually do this and and so we
started pouring that money on there and
of course me being the nerd I got out my
spreadsheet and I knew exactly to the
month when we were going to be out of
debt and our next goal was to you know
build out a vs. because we were on fire
to do that and we just had it we had
something that we were working for so
over the next three months she was in a
hospital and passed away in November of
2015
[Music]
I think back that she there was
opportunities playing to opportunities
that what we're getting I dead
everything she could had gone online or
you know Kim bought whatever she wanted
but she was really committed to this I
really never realized that somehow she
knew that uh maybe she wasn't gonna make
it
and how she did this for me
did this for me I remembered being in
the hospital and thinking about you know
baby steps and the month that which he
had gone hospital we had finished we got
to our three to six months and it was
quite amazing because I was sitting
there thinking this is really financial
piece this is what it's all about this
is what we work for but I could be off
for six months and not have anything hit
me no financial worries and even my kids
you know they were trying to balance
waiting for their FMLA time off how you
know how they going to float that little
time in it I was able you know to able
to stay here here's some money and no
worries right we got you we have that
that's what we that's what we've been
working for right I think that was a
huge blessing that we didn't really
realize that we were prepared for now
you just have that comfort that you can
make decisions the right decisions at
the right time and do whatever you need
to do for your family and take care of
yourself and when she passed away I had
that life insurance but it was enough to
pay off the house and was interesting
because I told God I was going to tide
on that and it's more than I've ever
tied my life and that week later
I'm stalking their long-term disability
provider and they said well you know she
had life insurance policy with us and I
said no I didn't know anything about
that and they said yeah we we've been
we've had that policy out since she was
injured six years ago we've been paying
the monthly premium on that and we have
a check for honor $20,000 for you and I
knew exactly what to do with it right
and I so I paid off my house is
incredible because it was like she and
God finish this so yeah yeah I would say
that that financial piece is really what
it is and it moves me on understanding
of and in going forward I mean I'm on my
third financial class now and to see the
changes of people you know it is my new
ministry it was God's coffee to do I
look at people and I and I can look at
them now and and I know
when they're afraid when you're stressed
out when couples come up to me I don't
have to say anything I just I know it
because I've been in their shoes I've
walked in their shoes
I've lived in their shoes I just want
that so much for them going forward
right that there's that they can have
what I have when we realized that we
were going to pay off of our debt and it
would take 20 months two years to do it
and I can tell you there's that moment
out the first year a year is a long time
and then you know that you have another
year to go and you think how can I
possibly do that that's the breaking
point
if perseverance right that gazelle
intensity the reason that you did that
being sick and tired of being sick and
tired you know realizing that there is a
plan for you to get out of debt that you
know as dave says you wander in debt but
you can't wander out and I would tell
you that it's so much more worth it than
you could ever understand God's got a
plan things don't just happen there's
always a reason one day
[Music]
[Applause]
you never know what's going to come out
you I look back and I think that we did
was and you know we paid off seventy
eight thousand dollars we've got our
emergency fund and then when passed away
I was able to pay off the house which is
a total of 108 thousand dollars and
thirty eight months sure is an
accelerated plan but it was sort of
something that we knew we needed to do
and we knew what we're going to do and
even though you know life is not
predictable certain things are when
you're in the control of your money
let's say a debt-free screen this is for
you honey
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you